[Musique]
nos fondamentaux c'est d'abord les
territoires nous sommes majoritaires sur
les territoires si on on prend
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des conseillers
municipaux départementaux et régionaux
ce sont les républicains qui sont
majoritaires sur le territoire on est
majoritaire au sénat
ça n'est pas rien non plus sinon je
pense que enfin je ne sais pas dans
quelle dérive institutionnelle en
saurait nous avons le premier groupe
parlementaire d'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale quel est le parti qui
aujourd'hui peut mobiliser presque 65
mille adhérents à jour de cotisation
pour élire son président dans un
exercice démocratique s'est parfaitement
déroulée les militants ont voté nombreux
62000 on nous disait deux fois mois donc
on est le premier parti de militants de
france
et puis le score de christian jacob est
sans appel
aujourd'hui le paysage politique
s'inscrit dans une dualité qui est
mortifère pour la démocratie il n'est
pas normal et c'est pour ça que je reste
fidèle aux républicains qu'on ait d'un
côté le choix entre emmanuel macron et
d'un autre marine le pen on a besoin
d'idées on a besoin de refaire notre
corpus idéologique n'a robe au besoin de
refaire un programme on a besoin de
refaire un projet que moi ça me choque
quand qu'on accepte effectivement qu'une
personne voilée puisse accompagner des
enfants déplacements scolaires parce que
comment expliquer que ces interdits dans
l'enceinte de l'établissement mais que
si on est au contact des enfants en
dehors et toujours dans le cadre
scolaire puisque c'est un voyage
scolaire
cancon lot toril le fait d'accompagner
des enfants en sortie scolaire n'aime
pas le fait d'accompagner son enfant
donc il se jouait ce que vous êtes en
train de nous dit c'est le foot pardon
de contribuer au travail de l'éducation
nationale et d'assumer un rôle
pédagogique
on n'a pas le droit de mettre un voile
quand on rentre comme acteur pédagogique
à l'école je crois qu'on ne devrait pas
non plus pouvoir accompagner des sorties
scolaires avec un voile ce que nous
voulons faire c'est très simple c'est
faire en sorte que l'école soit un
sanctuaire trop constitution prévoit que
la république française est laïque et
qu'elle respecte toutes les croyances
jacques thomas il ya une différence
entre respecter les croyances et tester
la république avec des provocations qui
ne sont pas dans le pacte républicain et
c'est
un sujet le voile parce que c'est un
élément de communication je pense qu'il
faut désarmer l'islam radical en france
et vous avez vu le flou du gouvernement
c'est parce qu'ils pensent à l'arrivée
faut que le président de la république
tranche un moment sur ces questions de
laïcité ça fait trois ans qu'il reporte
son discours et pendant ce temps le
communautarisme avance
[Musique]